玩具ドッキーバックらーん
バッグバックぬんぱーくブーン間近らくーだ爆弾が届きましたらあげてみましょう
ちょっと撮っちゃってるんですよね
おおおおおおお買い上げありがとうございます村のおまけですまい棒が入ってますね
あうんうん
うーんなにこれではもう完全にこれは1回にも合いやすいっていう商品ですこちら取っ
てるバックダーン
なんかも多分たくさん買ったんでしょうね俺僕おったんでして爆弾改定なと思って
人に頭おかしいのか圧迫が欲しいなんかもてアマゾンで調べたらこれが出てきたんで僕
はバックなんと2年式で買いました
すごい無し版で刷毛だけ買えるんだと思っても喜んでたぜってばもう
なにこれ食べ物ではありません口の中に絶対入れないでください開封せず遊ぶ商品です
絶対に開封しないで下さいどういうことどういうことどういうことでいいけどどういう
ことどういうこと港へ koikoi 全然わかんないけど開封する奴でしょこれは
は何ですなってわかんないわかんじゃない
猫はコレなになにこれ夜明けば書いてあることがすごいよこれ袋の中の小袋を指で一気
に押しつぶすと袋が膨らんできますね5秒以内に2メートル以上離れてください
音を立てて破裂します
ってやっぱで爆発ってこれだ角掛ダンサーまってまって俺をちょっと聞いてないよこう
いうのを
やけどだけでほしいとで買ったんで僕の責任なんですけども袋の中のコブクロってどう
いうことをこれ中にまだ入ってるってことを袋分けない遊ぶんだな
くって言ってますから多分これはもう開けちゃダメなとと思う押しつぶすとってご用意
やにディメートルを離れるのか
とりあえずだとこらへんまで2メートルあると思うので押しつぶすとプロが膨らむでも
密レスんだよね
いきます
はあああああ
だよこれ何とかあったっけ結構買ったぞこれはやばいやばいやばいやばい結構な量を
買ってしまった2つはこちらをれたことされたん体が素敵な優しい感じなのかと思っ
てるんですけどこれくればやんじゃない
ビットビビった実際扱いなこれは面白いけどもないなぁいいというわけで僕も本まで
さらなるスキルアップを目指してこういう爆弾とかがあってもなるべくリアクションせ
ず変えられる
有用な忍耐力北欲しいと思ってるんで今まとめて爆弾全部ここでは隠させて
頑張ります
ねぇもっと問題はあってこれをみんなみんな
けど中に袋が入っててポスト時間あれば気がするんだよ
みんな頑張ってる潰して全然あったらみんなも逃げていいよ1回事件だろうか
けるぞや
じゃあ行きます
水
トゥ
まーす
カラー
ああああああ
葉っぱ
はっはっは
ああああああ
はっはー ran じゃん
うわあああっパパ
はぁ
はっはっは
me
dea
car
wh 8版
もう大丈夫大丈夫でしょこれを知ってるほっぺたじゃん
we began
あっはっはちょっとってドッペルどもう大丈夫だよと
はございませんうん
はあああああ
ree
はぁ